well the ramen's always special we've
all had special moments here separately
but never
together so this is really cool well you
know even though the
the seats are empty right now
you feel like you're playing in front of
your heroes that played here before and
uh
i think the nature of this song is
is so rooted in songwriting and country
music that
it's it's it's very introspective
performance it's really
just good to get to the heart of the
matter i think that's if there's any
blessing in all the chaos
is that it's allowed a little more art
to lead
um i know for us it gave us a chance to
actually get to do this you know because
everybody was not on the road and
we got to really kind of live with
ourselves and live with these songs and
and uh i think a lot of artists are
there right now going hey
this is why we got into this in the
first place let's get back to that
and kind of start with a clean slate
well we've all been friends for a really
long time we're all from texas
if you couldn't tell um and we've been
going to this
magical place called martha texas for
the last six years writing songs and we
decided
you know during last year when not a lot
of us were driven by different career
things going on we wanted to put out the
marvel tapes just put out work tapes and
let people hear the songs in their
rawest form and uh
and i kind of can't believe we're
talking about it right here playing on
the acms like we just
were thinking it would be simple like
just put out our acoustic songs but
really turn into a big record and
for us all and it's really special too
no we're a band now we're a band
now we're not friends yeah we're not
talking
we have three buses i just i mean i feel
some days like i've been doing this
two days and some days like 200 years
but um
i feel you know honored and proud to
still be
part of the acm still be nominated that
my peers still think what i'm doing
matters and that the fans are still
there i'm
you know just kind of shocked every year
but very thankful